grace where are you you're making a huge
mistake
are you karen yes honey well
peter paul and mary you are fabulous
well thank you who are you
i'm jack jack oh
will's jack well hello honey we've
talked on the phone a million times i
can't believe they've never met
look at you you little hottie stand
no up on
look at you you are a rocket ship oh get
out of here are you
a strange person this is
what is this p.s
loving the boobs
perky with all kinds of attitude starbot
right ah god i had no idea you would be
so
kidding with a whip come on let's touch
stomachs
oh my lord you are a complete freak
oh look here stands well do you have a
will honey why do i need a whale i'm
gonna live forever
that is the deal isn't it redo
oh hey cara would you sure but you don't
even know that's great but if i told you
come on let's get started
oh my god that voice is ridiculous
oh hospitals are fun
even though one could never put a price
on the pain and suffering this has
caused me
one has jack i don't read
i'm red too
very well item one 500 000
paid to me by you over the next four
years preferably in 50s
item two a shetland pony dyed powder
blue to match my eyes
[Laughter]
item three powder blue eyes
item four wait a minute wait a minute
blanche i'm still on item one
five hundred thousand and fifties i've
always been turned on by one benji
franklin
he wasn't afraid to wear his hair up and
away from the face
franklin's on the hundred you mook and
where do you get off
asking me for 500k do you know how many
times i had to uh
oh my god stand up to get that
well we did have a contract i gave you a
year of my life so rosario could stay in
the country
i i don't think a trust fund and a
corvette is too much to ask for
are you kidding me with this i plucked
you out of a four by four hovel above a
blinking light in times square and put
you in a six by six maid's quarters on
park avenue and this is the things i get
hey you got something out of this too
missy who read valley of the dolls to
your kids every night
who distracted stan for you on oyster
tuesdays
me it was me now i owe my 5000 50s 50s
with ben franklin
you know you should think very carefully
about what you're asking for miss
gurley-brown
you've got a good thing going here and
if you think that you can just
shamelessly siphon cash off of a loved
one like i'm doing with my husband
you've got another thing coming
i want my money you ain't getting 88
cents from me rose
very well i will see you in court
by the way your boobs look great today
it's a custom-made jean-claude just came
in from paris yesterday now get out of
here
oh hey i've got an idea i'm going to the
barney sale with rosario this weekend
why don't you just come along
well i'll need a little money from the
atm
denied denied approved
here maybe this was a bad idea i mean
this doesn't even look like a movie set
hey come on just say what i told you
fine
i'm on the set of my new movie poorly
decorated crack house
[Applause]
directing is fun check it out jackie the
dude the diamonds and the dough
honey you're simple you're shallow and
you're a common [__] that's why we're
so much uh hello i can totally play
straight
oh honey no one in the world would
believe you are straight
you're as gay as a clutch purse on tony
night
[Laughter]
i fell out of the gay tree hitting every
gay branch on the way
and you landed on a gay guy
and you did him
[Applause]
no no honey your gayness can be seen
from space
but you're so gay
and will you be needing your own trailer
the word is
maitre d
uh that's not a gay word of a roller
disco
major d m
a
[Laughter]
m8
excuse me waiter i
would like some tea
i.t wait a minute carrot those almost
sound like letters
i'm sorry hag number 12 you're gonna
have to leave
m-a-i-t put your paws off of me
who do you think you are
m a i t
[Music]
[Applause]
would you keep her out of without my
here
this could end in a catastrophe
karen this isn't something you can run
away from it's not like a hotel bill or
a crying baby
there are poor people who dream their
whole lives of a meal like this
honey i know what we should do let's
take a picture of us eating and show it
to them
wow karen you are like a female jesus
i'm too tired to slap you bash your face
against my palm would you
jackie look at me i'm fox trotting
hardly what am i doing wrong
look some people were born to dance you
were born to drink
if you could cut a rug like you left a
mug i'd have something to work with
honey why are you being because just
like our friendship
this dance lesson as we know it is over
oh jackie that's what you're upset about
look i understand you love finney but
why do things have to change between us
because they have to every healthy
relationship between a gay man
and a straight woman has a sell-by date
do you really want to end up like will
and grace
you